what's going on with gambit I mean the
latest is we'll see I mean honestly like
since the merger happened I think all of
the movies that are at Fox not just the
Marvel movies but all the movies at Fox
are being evaluated and they'll figure
out what they want to do with them you
want to see it happen I would love to
see it happen I mean I love I love the
idea of Channing playing gambit I think
we have a great script for it and I
think it's a role he was born to play
it's a character I grew up loving and I
know the fans love so I suspect I hope
it'll happen
who's the one superhero you want to see
pop up in an x-men movie that you'd die
I mean I'm a I'm a fan of so many of
those MCU characters I guess I would say
probably either somebody from what Conda
or or Iron Man I mean I love Downey I've
worked with him I love what he does with
that character I feel like he created
the tonal template for the MCU with the
first Iron Man movie and so the notion
of Iron Man popping up in x-men or Iron
Man interacting with Deadpool is pretty
exciting x-men and Deadpool that's what
I vote for I think that would be pretty
amazing well we did a little bit of that
in Deadpool too like I shot a scene for
Deadpool to where they pop up and in
Deadpool 1 we had a reference where
Ryan's talking about the messed up
timelines of the x-men movies and so I
think there'll be a lot of mixing and
merging now and I'm and I'm all for it
and excited to see it's just a fan I'm
excited to see it hi everyone it's
Charlie so we got a whole bunch of new
Marvel phase 4 stuff to break down this
is Simon Kinberg if you don't know who
he is he was sort of the Kevin Feige of
Fox Marvel the last couple of years but
he's basically saying what's going on
post merger with all the big x-men films
that they hadn't development including
all the Deadpool stuff too so we'll
break all that down it's also pretty
cool to hear him talk about Iron Man
crossing over with Deadpool in the x-men
which may or may not confirm that he
survives into Marvel phase four there's
a lot of questions about who's gonna die
at the end of Avengers endgame is just
the beginning it's only gonna get
crazier in the next couple of months
with avengers endgame and all the other
movies that are coming this summer so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's a new brand of that IMAX ticket
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a Marvel or
x-men comment on the video so Simon
Kinberg is saying that they had all
these
x-men movies and development they're
actually several that I'll explain in
what's going on with each of them but he
says that right now Kevin Feige is
deciding what's gonna happen with all
those separate movies we have a pretty
good idea of which x-men movies are
gonna get thrown in the trashcan and
which movies Kevin Feige is gonna
continue to make the only exception to
this is Fantastic Four because as of the
Fox Disney deal of the last couple of
months there was no Fantastic Four movie
in development at box so there's just
fresh slate for them Kevin Feige will
reboot those characters you'll see them
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
eventually going down the x-men movie
list though we have Dark Phoenix coming
up this summer that's still coming out
of Jude that will be the very last x-men
tema
film that Fox makes the next time you
see an x-men film released by Marvel
it'll be Kevin Feige movie with versions
of characters that he's recast with a
brand new version of the team there's
always the very earliest that they could
get that out is in three years and
that's only if he started today like if
he's fielding scripts which probably
isn't happening because they're still
trying to get Avengers end game out and
he's trying to decide which of these
other movies that he's gonna throw in
the trash can and which one they're
gonna continue to develop so somewhere
in a back room there's a team of interns
on typewriters just coming up with
pitches and ideas for x-men movies that
he can then feel so eventually you'll
hear more about that this summer so
pretty much everybody in the entire
world who watches comic book films
understands that eventually there will
be another solo x-men film with a
different version of the team but here
we go next one though is New Mutants
you may have been hearing all the drama
behind the scenes Maisie Williams has
been doing all these interviews for Game
of Thrones Season eight people have been
asking you for updates on New Mutants is
that movie even coming out are they just
gonna throw it in the garbage what's
going on she says that she and the other
cast members have no idea when it's
going to be released there was supposed
to be a bunch of reshoot so that they
could turn it into a legit horror film
more of an r-rated film instead of pg-13
those never happened they hit the pause
button on production in the director
Josh Boone went on to another project
while the Fox Disney deal was going on
so right now there's a version of that
movie that's sitting on a shelf
somewhere and the current belief is is
that Disney will
either sort of tool it around and make
it more pg-13 and release it on the
Disney Plus streaming service when that
launches later this year or they'll let
it be legit horror film and they'll just
put it on hulu hulu is the place where
disney is putting all of its Deadpool
r-rated hardcore stuff anything that you
wouldn't consider family-friendly the
only f-bomb we're using around here it's
Fred Savage
so we'll eventually see that movie but
it'll probably be on one of those
streaming services the next big one is
Channing Tatum's gambit movie that Simon
Kinberg talks about during this
interviews I hope it still comes out
that was supposed to be set during the
1970s so Days of Future past era the
last big director said that he left the
movie after their budget got slashed in
the wake of Fantastic Four back in 2015
just completely bombing so that lets you
know how long that they've been trying
to get that gambit movie off the ground
if they've been working on it since
before the last Fantastic Four movie
came out odds are pretty good that that
never gets made Channing Tatum is a big
star he can totally sell movies but I
just don't see Kevin Feige letting that
character gambit go off by himself when
he could put him in a modern-day MCU
film there's Drew Goddard x-force film
that he's working on which is sort of
like the r-rated version of a big x-men
team-up film so like Deadpool films tend
to be a little bit smaller the budgets
aren't quite as big imagine Deadpool 2
if they did not kill off x-force and
they did a genuine x-force film and just
doubled the budget from now on will be
known as
x-force they were actually supposed to
go in production for that a while ago
but because of the Fox Disney deal the
pause button was hit and they're sort of
retooling what they're gonna do with the
next Deadpool film because they were
also gonna make Deadpool three after
they were gonna make exports but the CEO
of Disney Bob Iger said that they were
gonna continue to allow Deadpool to make
r-rated films but here's the thing Drew
Goddard who's supposed to be working on
that movie just signed a giant overall
deal at Fox to make TV shows for them so
how is he gonna do that and do the
x-force film at the same time it just
seems like they're not gonna make
x-force they'll just proceed on a
Deadpool three and somebody else will
work on that project but the good thing
about Drew Goddard though is is that
they'll probably have him develop Marvel
and x-men TV shows for the Disney Plus
streaming service because if you don't
know who Drew Goddard is he's the guy
who developed daredevil season 1 for
Netflix he's the one that made that show
what it is so he's one of those creative
genius as this sprung from the Whedon
burst so he's really good at what he
does he's an amazing writer so you
should be excited about anything that he
touches but because of this new TV deal
that he signed in the Disney Plus
streaming service and all the x-men TV
shows and Marvel TV shows they're gonna
be developing for it we probably won't
find out what exactly those are for
quite a while but just be excited that
he is now locked down under deal with
them meaning that you'll see a lot of
cool Marvel stuff coming from them no
idea who's gonna be writing and
directing Deadpool 3 they haven't
decided yet but they will make it there
will be more Deadpool films right now
Ryan Reynolds is the only one who's
expected to continue playing his
character going forward you could see
what all falls apart and quite frankly
why I prefer Marvel we are Marvel
ha-ha-hilarious your Fox so don't worry
about him Deadpool will be fine he'll
continue doing his thing but he also
might crossover with the other films but
in those cases he would be more pg-13 in
the vein of once upon a Deadpool as
opposed to the Deadpool solo films Regis
continues on being as hardcore and
r-rated as he wants to be it's just that
now he can take more shots at all the
other Marvel films because there's no
question about using IP like you could
put anybody you want to in those
Deadpool films like Simon Kinberg says I
would love to see Robert Downey jr. Iron
Man in a Deadpool film although I don't
expect that to happen any
I'm soon there was the kitty pryde movie
that Bendis and tim miller for the
director of the first deadpool movie
were making that's still happening
Bendis said that he was still working on
it as of January February so apparently
it's still in development kitty pryde
probably one of the most popular x-men
characters she's one of those characters
that you could put in almost any of
those big Marvel films that are coming
up during phase four and she would be
really cool but there was the James
Franco multiple man movie which is now
probably gonna get thrown in the garbage
can literally nothing has been said
about it in the last year or two since
they announced that he has started to
work on it there was a dr. doom solo
film that Noah Hawley was making if you
don't know who he is he's the person
that makes the Legion TV show he makes a
lot of really weird really cool stuff so
he's really good at what he does but his
Doctor Doom film was supposed to be a
little bit smaller he didn't say exactly
which other characters showed up during
that but it was mostly set in and around
La Parrilla he said that he met with
Kevin Feige recently to talk about his
film but he gave him his script for that
Doctor Doom film Kevin Feige has not
read it yet or given him any feedback so
he doesn't know if his Doctor Doom film
is gonna get made I don't think that it
will I think we'll just see dr. doom pop
up in somebody else's film then lastly
number one there was a Bryan cave on
Silver Surfer movie that he was working
on I'm also expecting that that's gonna
get thrown in the garbage can and
they'll just put Silver Surfer in
somebody else's movie either Fantastic
Four or another x-men movie or a big
Marvel Studios crossover film let me
know if you have any big questions about
Marvel phase 4 or Avengers and game or
things that you want me to make videos
for what'll happen is I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post my next
Marvel video click here for that brand
new Avengers endgame trailer - they just
dropped and click here for that brand
new spider-man far from home promo thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]